foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm super dog
it's not simple I'm just being a good
teammate we'll blame it on the ping yeah
blame it on these nuts they're really
cold my balls are starting to get a bit
warm
by the way twitch as he as he leaves he
says I shall be back later on and potato
is thick and great at the game wow how
sweet not nice
oh wait no you're a girl never mind
Captain come here
wait what we must collect the spices
like if we are women
okay
no
no oh you're hot
up here
it's not so tough after all
[Music]
okay here muted thanks bye
love you too I love you
we're going B and ALT B please wall and
ALT B
why don't you ask nicely you dumb
and all like how hard is it for you to
[ __ ]
understanding child to you you were
being so rude
the last thing I will do is listen to
you
potato you're heaven
you like juice wrld
seconds left
yeah I don't like him either
what rapper do you like I don't like rap
what kind of I don't like crap either
what kind of songs like I don't know rap
just kind of trash to be honest
I have potato I have a question my chat
wants to ask you a question it's kind of
weird though
what
all right so what's that
[Music]
mine online
next
you guys are boring I'm not gonna lie
yeah
I'm asking potato of course she doesn't
want to answer it why don't you ask in
your team member for example there is
Silva Andrews omen
what about them
ask them the question all right boys
did y'all see that flick
come on man I was kind of space
you [ __ ] sounds so sexy I don't want
to change my name to tomato
why so I could be her potato
a potato
what come here
oh
that's the horny
a real gentleman right
I'm looking scared bro I'm getting
tremored on my you're so good potato
you're so good potato
I'll just skip ahead you know when I oh
Jesus Christ when I see [ __ ] nerds
that's that
like it's like it's like it's like
cat calling we've been video games
[ __ ] nerds but right just just just
just in general not even being a girl
playing games online
these [ __ ] are wild
they say the foul is [ __ ] doesn't matter
if they're nine or whatever you're old
these people are wow
s you play online games like that you're
gonna hear some foul [ __ ] now you're a
girl that's just oh you're just being
weird God damn get it right oh my gosh
anyone got a mic
I do now I'm just kidding we all got
mics we're in Discord though but
fastest mutant the West
silk potato
are you a real gamer I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm so crazy I'm sorry
you are a definition of cringe right now
oh yeah
oh
no no no no no no you moan like that and
you say sorry
oh you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think I can I think I can I think what
are you thinking
is so he can get his dream hot potato
Viper Viper stay behind me I'll protect
you stay behind me I'll protect you oh
my gosh
should we move this look at your Discord
oh you're good you're good
oh well I get your Discord I didn't
agree to that
uh look you click or like it's like a
female trying to pick where to go to eat
Jesus Christ yo
you know imagine all these fans
I haven't only fans I haven't put my
long schlong on the [ __ ] cam
yo Viper
Viper let's guard
hello
hey yo potato uh Frost want your cake
if you win I'll give you this [ __ ]
schmee
I didn't really want that so
thank you
thanks for Nate thanks for letting me
know that's racist
hey I'm sexist not racist to the
difference
yo kill Drive
I'll find them you got a girlfriend
yeah
I saw it
let them try like you trade a skin for a
basic I had a stinger here to vandals
priorities
huh
oh nothing yeah all right he stutters
when um he's around Ladies sorry I'm
sorry what do you guys X and Y
chromosomes
there's no way you just asked that
what's your name
mine it means
oh classy
it's tight
tight you're right
exactly oh
can I put you a song potato
um
why
someone accept me this and then what do
you think do you feel like women in
games or this that
so let me see this as a black doodoo
games okay at the moment people suspect
I'm black uh and bombs start flying
everywhere I don't get [ __ ] up
um and what I realized was online gaming
in general is pretty toxic to begin with
all right people will say stuff to each
other and then if they find any angle on
you be it female or be it black or any
race okay
then they'll go down that road to say
something is harmful because there's no
repercussions right there doing it from
the luxury of their home so they feel
very safe and all this other stuff so
that's the first part the second part is
generally from my experience The Gaming
Community you have like two branches
right you have to do two like super
simple for for gamer girls okay right
which you saw in this video guys just
like can I give you a gun can I do this
can I do this right because they're like
so awkward among women such losers yeah
they can't help but do that yeah then
yeah the other side super success which
is like they see that and then they
think Ultra on the other side they're
like oh
fake women gaming blah blah blah blah
this is crazy right and you have a small
swing of people like they just don't
care it's just normal they don't kiss it
my experience online I've seen lobbies
the moment the girl just uses her voice
message like bro the whole Lobby like
the whole group changes oh oh you're a
girl well uh
hi what is this like you're gonna meet
the [ __ ] how much of a loser are you
you know what I'm saying like you doing
all this extra stuff can I get your
Discord after friend request then you'll
see the other people the dudes who hate
on them really hard you [ __ ] loser
you this and that you this and that then
the friend request them afterwards yeah
yeah yeah because you're doing like that
Middle School [ __ ] where you hate on
the girl you like or whatever okay my
cringe The Gaming Community
so much cringe and losers is
unbelievable I don't even know what to
say because I didn't know about that
committee a bit but I don't really
indulge in it right but what what that
oh yeah oh yeah it's not helping me and
for reinforce the positive
opinion opinion of the gaming community
and it should because it's not it's like
here's the thing The Gaming Community is
an interesting one there's good and
they're super toxic Parts all right so
it's a mixture of those things yeah but
I do know for a lady you either follow
the super Sim category or the I hate
ladies category and that's generally in
my experience even watching like
coverage of a lot of these things where
like a twitch stream or whatever yeah
and to be fair like yo there's some of
these ladies who do this stuff who like
they just get off by their looks you
know what I'm saying whereas like a dude
might have to work whatever A lot of
these ladies just come on with their
titties popping out their turtlenecks
right as Dave Chappelle would say and
they're getting like stuff so it's a
whole convoluted thing right because you
have these like generally socially
awkward people who people are not as
good socially interacting with these
women from the comfort of their home and
the dynamic is nice yeah it is it's kind
of gross yeah because they can do
whatever the hell they want yeah yeah it
doesn't really want me to
go into online gaming of course not Hey
listen imagine any other Hobby
any other hobby maybe you're in a dance
class and dudes was talking to women
like that
could you imagine that yeah can you
imagine it was [ __ ] up you can't
imagine it because you've never seen
anything like that because boys at least
imagine girls don't even want to go to
the gym no more because some dudes are
creepy yeah but now they just looking
staring Sometimes they come up and say a
comment and they don't even like that
like that yeah and they come up in a
spot saying a bunch of weird [ __ ]
gaming is an extra level it's it's it's
uh yeah it's weird it doesn't want me to
doesn't make me want to game with other
people
yeah yeah I would say I would say
generally my experience online gaming is
like pretty tame and chill depending on
what game but I have noticed the moment
anyone's like are you black yeah I'm
like hey you you are hard mutes hard
hard I just mute hard R hard anything it
doesn't matter it's very it's very
awkward to be online but that's been my
experience but I just want to touch on
this when I get too deep into it but
let's know what you think would you guys
agree or disagreed you feel like we're
being unfair we want to hear from you
guys in the comments below and shout out
to the lady I'll link to her video in
the description Jesus freaking Christ